have you thought about how many more
years you want to give this thing um I
think that yeah I think I'm probably
done I think that probably a part of me
had accepted it a little bit even before
I did this Facebook hello Hannah how are
you all right I'm good right Elias I'm
doing well you know I was just thinking
about the load X coming back and we're
not gonna get to hear crazy on the board
and then I had another 12 months of it
yes it's been brought to my attention
that you
ladies don't touch me how are you
feeling about season five all gorgeous
it's definitely a different season I
feel like it's pantheon is almost every
year we're hitting the reset button and
trying to have a healthy work
relationship so yeah we do that again
Sandee responds very well to people who
[Music]
not good I'm much more ever like I'm
here to do my job I have respect you
with my captain but at the same time you
know I I do say no to her sometimes
which I don't think sound very well and
I feel like last season you know she
said that I wasn't passionate about
yawning which is a difficult one to
tackle this is not saying you don't care
I just thought you know this is your
passion yawning is not your passion yeah
I'm not I'm not passionate about fights
and machines and ankle watches and how
things work on those I am very
passionate about making sure that the
guests have a good time I believe I do
that like you know we had the whole last
season where we just have one guest and
play the whole time am i passionate
about putting like plastic rots and fake
flowers on the table right and it's not
my style
okay yes we kind of butt heads with that
because what she sees is like good like
table decor I see is tacky so we
struggle with that
I fired you a long time ago Hannah last
year before
have you thought about how many more
years you want to give this thing um I
think that yeah I think I'm probably
done okay after this season you think
you're done yeah interesting that's two
big blows for the world of below deck
oh just have Kate leave and then you to
leave would be quite the double whammy
yeah Mike sandy said it's really not my
passion in life when I first started
yawning when I am I very early 20s you
know I would see these women who are in
their late 30s and early 40s sitting in
a bar getting wasted with 20 year old
living in a tiny cabin and outside I
don't want to get to the stage where I'm
locked into yachting and there's nothing
else in my life except that it's
different if you're a captain but
there's a cheap juice they just don't
seem like very happy people to me will
we see you grapple with that decision or
like kind of get into that mindset of
realizing this is the last go on this
season I think that probably a part of
me had accepted it a little bit even
before I did this season I think that
with yawning you really have to be like
been done with it before you can
probably walk away otherwise you're
constantly questioning yourself about
did I do the right thing should I've
done one more season on this earth yeah
I think it was I think there's probably
a part of me knew that before I even
bowling season Wow
what does life after yachting look like
I am really settled here in Sydney I
have my partner and my dog and they
bring needs more happiness than anything
that you know in my house but that's
very good
and yeah I just like to settle down and
working for me and hopefully I have a
rug rat or two and yeah concentrate on
life that sort of stuff so family life
isn't it next yeah definitely
piss me off the less I will do I don't
think your attitudes very good to be
together and be nice
stop talking I'm not there is a lot of
drama teased in that trailer and Lara is
yes she's just she's in a league of her
own that one I thought I had seen bad
Amara when you have a stewardess that is
that insubordinate you can't work as a
team so it was definitely a very trying
Septimus is been probably the most
difficult start to the season I've had
in all of my below deck space so yeah
that was a great way to start was it
difficult just because of her
it was difficult in a lot of ways there
was the first season that I've ever done
where I had a boyfriend at home another
like layer of complexity to the
situation and then coming off the back
of last season when I was told by Sandy
that I wasn't passionate about my job I
really put my head down and worked as
hard as I could've met you know but
enough then I'm not sure where I can go
from here okay so you had a boyfriend
back home while you are off on this
yachting season does this mean this is
going to be the first below deck Med
season where we don't see Hannah hooking
up with somebody on board the ship yes
that's how this season is different yeah
you guys if you had to pick between
working with Lara again or chef Mila
again who would you pick I would
probably pick Mela why are we using a
box better though so that you don't tell
me I got you babe I use this American
what everybody [ __ ] uses yeah but if
you're a chef and you don't know how to
make compan cake better that's a bit of
a problem when it's a chef like I'm one
step removed so what she does it affects
the guests and it does affect me but
it's not my responsibility so there is a
certain level of like this is really not
my problem whereas Mara was really my
problem okay Wow looks like what's the
good thing of that Lara well she didn't
roll me that should stop you could try
to microwave me
very easy question anything else you
want to share about season five and kind
of the journey we're gonna see you on
this year I think it's definitely
different to any season the viewers have
ever seen before when it comes to me it
might be that they watch the season and
go you can tell she's over it or you can
tell they feel bad or I'm really not
sure so I'm interested to see it as they
yeah okay
well I'm excited to watch it'll be
exciting to see for the first time in
the show's history a woman at the helm
of every main position how did you feel
about that it was a little bit different
for me because I have a past with Malia
so I'm not sure if I wouldn't be more
excited if it was a different woman
coming in as a bosun
but to me I guess like the most
important thing is like just I don't
really care if you're a male or a female
just don't bid and that makes my working
life easier so yeah I think it's
definitely something that the viewers
will find interesting love in words of
wisdom I don't care after I met our
female just
[Music]